wir sind in der schule guten morgen
liebe kinder
in der heutigen stunde werden wir
darüber sprechen was eure wünsche und
träume für die zukunft sind
fangen wir also an
guten morgen liebe kinder
der heutigen stunde werden wir darüber
sprechen was eure wünsche und träume für
die zukunft sind
fangen wir also an
ich möchte mit luca beginnen
luca teil uns deine wünsche mit
guten morgen frau sommer ich möchte
fußballer werden wenn ich groß bin
denn ich liebe fußball und ich möchte
eines tages in einem berühmten verein
spielen und die weltmeisterschaft
gewinnen denn ich liebe fußball und ich
möchte eines tages in einem berühmten
verein spielen und die weltmeisterschaft
gewinnen
mein vater ist fitnesstrainer und ich
trainiere viermal pro woche mit ihm
ich muss hart trainieren um mir eines
tages meinen traum zu erfüllen
ok luca vielen dank dass du uns deine
wünsche mitgeteilt hast
alexandre du bist dran
mein vater ist arzt und ich wünschte ich
könnte wie er sein
deshalb möchte ich wenn ich groß bin
medizin studieren um ein angesehener
arzt wie mein vater zu werden deshalb
möchte ich wenn ich groß bin medizin
studieren um ein angesehener arzt wie
mein vater zu werden er sagt ich müsse
mich in meinem studium sehr anstrengen
wenn ich eines tages ein guter arzt
werden will
er sagt ich müsse mich in meinem studium
sehr anstrengen wenn ich eines tages ein
guter arzt werden will
das stimmt alexandre du musst sehr
diszipliniert sein damit du dir deinen
traum erfüllen kannst das stimmt
alexandre du musst sehr diszipliniert
sein damit du dir deinen traum erfüllen
kannst
sommer ich möchte ihnen auch meine
wünsche sagen
frau sommer ich möchte ihnen auch meine
sichert ihren
sag uns was du werden möchtest oder was
du gerne machen würdest wenn du
erwachsen bist
sichert ihren
sag uns was du werden möchtest oder was
du gerne machen würdest wenn du
erwachsen bist
ich hätte gerne viel geld um die welt zu
reisen und andere kulturen kennenlernen
zu können
ich hätte gerne viel geld um die welt zu
reisen und andere kulturen kennenlernen
zu können
und wie wirst du deine reise finanzieren
ich werde im lotto gewinnen
ich werde im lotto gewinnen sehr guten
ein positives denken gefällt mir sehr
gut
ein positives denken gefällt mir wohin
möchtest du reisen
wohin möchtest du reisen
ich möchte in die türkei reisen
ich möchte in die türkei reisen ich
möchte ihre kultur ihr essen und ihre
bräuche kennenlernen
meine mutter sagt dass das glück des
menschen im reisen liegt ich möchte ihre
kultur ihr essen und ihre bräuche
kennenlernen meine mutter sagt dass das
glück des menschen im reisen liegt
vielen dank tieren
ich bin mir sicher dass du mit viel
arbeit und deine kreativität deinen
traum verwirklichen kannst
vielen dank tieren
ich bin mir sicher dass du mit viel
arbeit und deine kreativität deinen
traum verwirklichen kannst
ich möchte jura studieren und eine
ausgezeichnete anwältin werden
und ich würde auch gerne ein großes haus
kaufen in dem meine ganze familie wohnen
kann
und ich würde auch gerne ein großes haus
kaufen in dem meine ganze familie wohnen
kann
ich möchte auch ein auto kaufen damit
ich mit meinen eltern an den strand
fahren kann
ich möchte auch ein auto kaufen damit
ich mit meinen eltern an den strand
fahren kann
sehr schöne wünsche und wenn du nicht
jura studiert was möchtest du dann noch
studieren
sehr schöne wünsche und wenn du nicht
jura studiert was möchtest du dann noch
studieren
wenn ich aus irgendeinem grund nicht
jura studieren könnte würde ich gerne
betriebswirtschaft studieren wenn ich
aus irgendeinem grund nicht jura
studieren könnte würde ich gerne
betriebswirtschaft studieren
ich mag zahlen und mein vater könnte mir
helfen denn er ist buchhalter
interessant leer ich danke dir
ich möchte tierärztin werden wenn ich
groß bin denn ich mag tiere
ich möchte tierärztin werden dann ich
mein haustier ist ein hund und ich
kümmere mich um ihn und passe auf ihn
auf mein haustier ist ein hand und ich
auf
mein größter traum ist es meine eigene
tierklinik zu besitzen damit ich allen
tieren helfen kann wenn sie krank sind
mein größter traum ist es meine eigene
tierklinik zu besitzen dann wirklich
allen tieren helfen kann wenn sie
grenzen
was für ein schöner wunsch selina
michael möchtest du ingenieur werden
wenn du erwachsen bist
nein frau sommer dieser beruf würde mir
nicht gefallen denn ich glaube ich kann
nicht so gut mit zahlen umgehen
nein frau sommer dieser beruf würde mir
nicht gefallen denn ich glaube ich kann
nicht so gut mit zahlen umgehen
ich möchte gerne koch werden ich möchte
mein eigenes restaurant haben und essen
für die menschen zu bereiten
ich möchte gerne koch werden ich möchte
mein eigenes restaurant haben und essen
für die menschen zu bereiten
zuhause helfe ich meiner mutter beim
abendessen zu hause helfe ich meiner
mutter beim abendessen
und am wochenende gehen wir immer in ein
anderes restaurant zum essen ich würde
gerne für viele menschen kochen und am
wochenende gehen wir immer in ein
anderes restaurant zum essen
ich würde gerne für viele menschen
kochen wenn ich die schule beenden werde
ich die aufnahmeprüfung für die
kochschule ablegen und der beste koch in
europa werden wenn ich die schule
beenden werde ich die aufnahmeprüfung
für die kochschule ablegen und der beste
koch in europa werden
[Applaus]
ich mag es dass du große träume hast ich
bin mir sicher dass du es schaffst
bin mir sicher dass du es schaffst frau
sommer ich möchte ihnen meine träume und
wünsche mitteilen
frau sommer ich möchte ihnen meine
träume und wünsche mitteilen
sicher thomas nur zu sicher thomas nur
zu
wenn ich groß bin möchte ich ein
flugzeug fliegen können
deshalb möchte ich eine ausbildung zum
pilot machen
ich möchte verkehrs pilot werden und
menschen an ihre verschiedenen ziele
befördern
ich möchte verkehrs pilot werden und
menschen an ihre verschiedenen ziele
befördern
[Musik]
ich träume auch davon zu heiraten und
kinder zu haben
ich möchte eine familie gründen ich
träume auch davon zu heiraten und kinder
zu haben
ich möchte eine familie gründen naja
thomas du denkst wie ein erwachsener
naja thomas du denkst wie ein
erwachsener mit dem gehalt das sich als
pilot verdiene werde ich genug geld
sparen um ein haus für mich und meine
zukünftige familie zu kaufen
mit dem gehalt das sich als pilot
verdiene werde ich genug geld sparen um
ein haus für mich und meine zukünftige
familie zu kaufen
die meisten schülerinnen und schüler
sind sich einig dass sie ein haus kaufen
oder reisen wollen
die meisten schülerinnen und schüler
sind sich einig dass sie ein haus kaufen
oder reisen wollen
es ist schön dass sie sich bereits um
ein dach über dem kopf sorgen und das
sie reisen wollen um andere kulturen
kennenzulernen
es ist schön dass sie sich bereits um
ein dach über dem kopf sorgen und das
sie reisen wollen um andere kulturen
kennenzulernen
mag ich würde gerne deine wünsche hören
ich möchte keinen chef haben der mir
sagt was ich tun soll
aus diesem grund würde ich gerne mein
eigenes unternehmen haben das
technologie verkauft
aus diesem grund würde ich gerne mein
eigenes unternehmen haben das
technologie verkauft
ich würde gerne alle arten von geräten
verkaufen
ich würde am liebsten etwas studieren
das mit management zu tun hat so dass
ich mein geschäft selbst führen kann
ich würde am liebsten etwas studieren
das mit management zu tun hat so dass
ich mein geschäft selbst führen kann
meine mutter wünschte ich wäre ein
künstler wie sie aber sie versteht dass
ich andere dinge mag meine mutter
wünschte ich wäre ein künstler wie sie
aber sie versteht dass ich andere dinge
mag
auf der anderen seite möchte mein vater
dass ich sprachen studieren aber ich bin
nicht so gut entsprachen
auf der anderen seite möchte mein vater
dass ich sprachen studieren aber ich bin
nicht so gut entsprachen
das sind meine wünsche frau sommer das
sind meine wünsche frau sommer ich
verstehe
danke dass du uns deine wünsche
mitgeteilt hast ich verstehe
mitgeteilt hast was ist mit dir an
sag uns bitte was du später werden
möchtest
was ist mit dir an
sag uns bitte was du später werden
möchtest
ich wäre glücklich auf der bühne ich
würde gerne eine berühmte sängerin sein
deshalb werde ich musik studieren damit
ich mir meinen traum erfüllen kann
ich würde mich freuen wenn die leute die
lieder singen würden die ich schreibe
außerdem wären meine lieder der
reisepass um die welt kennenzulernen
ich würde um die welt reisen meinen kids
spielen und viele leute treffen
ich würde um die welt reisen meine hits
meine eltern würden sich freuen wenn ich
musik studieren würde
musik studieren würde welches instrument
würdest du gerne spielen lernen welches
instrument würdest du gerne spielen
lernen
ich würde gerne gitarre und
klavierspielen lernen
ich könnte auch mit meinem vater proben
denn er spielt gitarre
er ist der superstar der familie ich
könnte auch mit meinem vater proben denn
er spielt sehr gut gitarre
er ist der superstar der familie sehr
interessant an
ich gratuliere dir zu deinem wunsch die
welt mit deiner musik zu erobern
sehr interessant an ich gratuliere dir
zu deinem wunsch die welt mit deiner
musik zu erobern
sophie wir würden gerne deine träume und
wünsche hören
nun frau sommer ich würde wirtschaft
studieren
ich kann gut mit zahlen umgehen und es
wäre ein gutes studium denn damit hätte
ich viele arbeitsmöglichkeiten
ich kann gut mit zahlen umgehen und es
wäre ein gutes studium denn damit hätte
ich viele arbeitsmöglichkeiten
ich könnte in einer bank arbeiten in
einem unternehmen oder für den staat
kurz gesagt es gäbe viele
beschäftigungsmöglichkeiten
meine mutter ist betriebs ökonomen und
es geht ihr sehr gut
sie würde sich freuen weil sie möchte
dass ich den gleichen beruf studieren
wenn ich aus der schule komme werde ich
mich an der uni bewerben und ein
wirtschaftsstudium beginnen wenn ich aus
der schule komme werde ich mich an der
uni bewerben und ein wirtschaftsstudium
beginnen
aber meine eltern wollen dass ich in
einem anderen land studiere deshalb
werde ich nach frankreich reisen um dort
zu studieren
aber meine eltern wollen dass ich in
einem anderen land studiere deshalb
werde ich nach frankreich reisen um dort
zu studieren
ich würde gerne einen guten job bekommen
der genug geld einbringt um reisen zu
können
ich würde gerne einen guten job bekommen
der genug geld einbringt um reisen zu
können denn das ist eine andere sache
die ich tun möchte reisen und viele
länder kennenlernen
denn das ist eine andere sache die ich
tun möchte reisen und viele länder
kennenlernen
nun kinder ich höre euren träumen und
wünschen gerne zu und hoffe von ganzem
herzen dass ihr sie erfüllen könnt nun
kinder
ich höre euren träumen und wünschen
gerne zu und hoffe von ganzem herzen
dass ihr sie erfüllen könnt deshalb
müsst ihr weiterhin fleißig lernen damit
ihr all diese träume erreichen könnt
deshalb müsst ihr weiterhin fleißig
lernen damit ihr all diese träume
erreichen könnte der beste weg die
zukunft vorherzusagen ist sie zu
schaffen der beste weg die zukunft
vorherzusagen ist sie zu schaffen wenn
wir nicht hart dafür arbeiten werden wir
nie die zukunft erreichen die wir uns
wünschen wenn wir nicht hart dafür
arbeiten werden wir nie die zukunft
erreichen die wir uns wünschen
vergesst nicht dass alles was ihr euch
vorgenommen habt erreicht werden kann
wenn ihr euch mit mühe und engagement
dafür einsetzt
vergesst nicht dass alles was ihr euch
vorgenommen habt erreicht werden kann
wenn ihr euch mit mühe und engagement
dafür einsetzt
ihr könnt jetzt gehen ich wünsche euch
ein schönes wochenende
tschüss ihr könnt jetzt gehen
ich wünsche euch ein schönes wochenende
tschüss
was sind deine wünsche was möchtest du
noch machen was sind deine wünsche was
möchtest du noch machen schreibt sie in
die kommentare schreibt sie in die
kommentare
auf wiedersehen